[Music]
greetings of peace assalamualaikum we
are in New Jersey filming in front of a
live audience and we have an incredible
topic as we always do now for the
university audience people sometimes
they come to the university they come to
the school and you know what you can
relate to this when you're studying hard
but then you have maybe a friend who can
help you excel or that friend can help
you maybe cut class and then you end up
drifting off and then you end up
flunking out but what about flunking out
on a bigger scale and now you end up
failing the test the test that the
crater is testing us with so we're gonna
be talking about this very important
topic how not how to pass your exams at
school but also passed the test of life
with my next guest when we come back
here we got a surprise for you he's been
on a Dean show before he's back with us
again with our brother I won't tell you
his name until I come back
sit tight number anywhere here on the D
show
[Music]
this is the nose not just me of course
so most people they know you they
remember we did a show at you Wesley yes
and this was talking about your story on
how you came to Islam correct
how you been since then how many like
everything I just recap for those that
haven't watched that show that we did
just in a condensed version just tell us
a little bit you know about your story
you know how you ended up coming over to
Islam from your previous life um real
brief basically I was born Christian
parents first generation in this country
when I was around hit my teens early
teens around 7th grade I started to
stray stop going to church my
grandmother and I were the most
religious people in my family they were
the ones who used to take us to church
and keep us on task but once I had 7th
grade I started drinking partying as I
basically increased in grade and age
basically became worse and said I hit
maybe about 17 18 and basically I had
crashed hard I was crashed my car drunk
I got into fights and almost was killed
after being jumped a few times and like
just progressed to get ready to get
worse
around 1920 I joined a gang called Zulu
Nation because there was a young man who
lived in my house who was a foster child
by the name of Edgar who was part of
this gang
he took us there introduced us to this
gang Zulu Nation and there we
brother named Abdulaziz who I came home
from prison who was also Puerto Rican
and he invited us to his home he said
can you bring me tea to my house and you
know when we got to his house he invited
us up for some tea and some biscuits and
cookies and stuff like this and he began
to talk to us about the concept of
tawheed the oneness of God and after
hearing that concept going back to him a
few times or several times and talking
about this concept until he the oneness
of God we ended up realizing that Islam
was the religion that we definitely
wanted to choose in the religion for us
and we became Muslim would you say that
this person that you got around now this
was a good friend a good companion
someone that helped you now explain to
you what the truth was so you got around
some good company I got around semi good
company semi good company and the reason
I say that is because I think he knew
many of his shortcomings coming home
from prison and because he knew his
shortcomings and he wanted good for us
once he gave us the foundation and he
knew that we had the foundation and then
he gave us the tools so that we can go
on and continue learning and growing but
and then he removed himself from the
picture because today when I think back
at that point I feel that he wasn't
ready to take on that responsibility of
leadership for us I see yes so people
can relate I was talking about when I
opened the program that when you're
studying hard in school you can have
good friends that encourage you and
they're good companions they study with
you they push you and then you end up
excelling but on the flip side you can
have some bad friends and maybe now
they're more concerned about going to
the frat party they're more concerned
about doing other things and now you end
up flunking out right but then I
compared it to the test of life so we
want to talk about in this episode the
value of having good company and really
you know what Islam says about this and
how you now as a Muslim how you
benefited from obviously being around
the right company well the major thing
that comes to mind is a hadith or a
narration by a beloved prophet may peace
and blessings of God be upon him where
he said a young daughter I have no clue
menu Harlan for Laura Zulu
connealy on rajala Dean honey he said
let each one of you be aware of who you
befriend for Eberly a man is upon the
religion of his friend and we have a
similar saying amongst you know just the
people of here in America right tell me
who you hang with and I'll tell you who
you are right birds will flock fly
together and it's a true statement and
this particular statement as a Muslim
personally helped me a lot because when
I accepted Islam my company at the time
was bad company right we would go out
drinking together we will go out smoking
together we were fornicating together we
will go out selling drugs together and
this is what I was accustomed being
around so when I accepted Islam and I
became a Muslim nothing really changed
except that now I believed in a new
faith I changed my belief from
worshipping Jesus which I really never
worship Jesus cuz I had a problem with
it but now to worshipping Allah God
Almighty Himself
but when I realized that in order for me
to change I had to change my company and
it wasn't until I changed my company
that life began to change for me and I
began to see something sweeter and
something better at the end of the road
now is it true that those people who are
a good company those same friends that
you have that you'd be friend in this
life reminds me of how the hadith for
the Prophet SAW some said that you know
a person will be with whom he loves so
now if you're hanging around with people
who are not reminding you of Allah your
mission in life your Creator you know
they're reminding you more about you
know some of the bad things that are out
there you know where do you think
where's the end result of that as
opposed to the end result if you have
people reminding you about the purpose
of life you know select you know Hajj
you know and all the other you know
beautiful things that we should be doing
so what the opposing hose well you if
you have that person who's always
calling you - good then naturally you're
gonna end up doing good right because
the Prophet gives another example he
says that good company is like being
around the must seller the person who
sells sweet
neither comes home and you buy something
from him and you benefit from it or you
leave from his shop smelling good right
or the evil or you be with the evil
person and he's like the one who makes
the sword the blacksmith right you
either your clothes get burnt from the
fire being jumped off or you leave with
this bad odour right and this is what
it's like in life and one of the most
important things that comes to mind for
me is a scenario true scenario and that
I and I'm a teacher so I always use
these scenarios to try to educate my
students a scenario of a college student
who went to a college who didn't have a
big MSA so she didn't have a lot of
Muslims around her and the only company
she had were not Muslims so naturally
they want a party they want to have fun
and she didn't want to feel left out and
because she didn't want to feel left out
they told to come with us to a party one
day so she goes to the party and at the
party she's drinking soda juice she's
not dancing with men she's not jumping
around in the party she's not drinking
alcohol she's trying to hold on to her
faith but she's a little ignorant of the
scenario that she's in so when she's not
paying attention and of course of
friends are partying and jumping around
and dancing and having fun while she's
watching she's not paying attention to
her drink and they put something in a
drink and her friends are not paying
attention to her now her drink was
spiked the men who spiked her drink took
her they raped her all night long
three men after this alhamdulillah all
praise is due to God that they were
caught because they recorded it but when
they called her father the police
officer in the morning and her father
got the call and said we have some bad
news your daughter was just raped and
molested last night
her father caught a heart attack and
died on the spot something that now this
young woman has to deal with a bad
choice perhaps going out with these
friends who were leading her to
something that wasn't good and an
outcome
in effect her father dying not only her
being molested we're now losing her
father on top of that this is a true
story and this is this is something now
that from this you know experience we
can all benefit to help you know us to
not fall in these traps we got so much
more to talk about we're gonna go ahead
and take off from there when we come
back on this story I got some questions
to ask you here on the D show don't go
anywhere
please subscribe to the D show follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]
welcome back to the Dene show and now
this story you're talking about so let's
go ahead and diagnosis again so this is
a a woman was a Muslim woman she ended
up going to she was called by some not
so good friends to go to a party and at
this party you know some men actually
put some drugs in her drink
we call they spiked her drink that you
call it and it's kind of just so how see
this is sometimes people they look at
Islam as being too stringent and strict
right
but how now can people relate because
usually it's the end consequences that
people don't think about it right so
there are some you know as they say you
know doctor can tell you you know as
ounce of prevention is better than a
pound of cure because once you got the
ailment the disease is hard sometimes to
get rid of it so would you say that now
a lot of times these guidelines these
perimeters are set by the Creator so you
don't end up going outside in an area
where you can end up having something
real harmful to that it's gonna happen
to you so would you say all these things
are set from a law out of his love for
us definitely out of his love his mercy
his generosity his kindness because
ultimately he's the Creator he's the
all-knowing right the all-wise he knows
why he sent these lost to us he knows
why he sent these regulations to us and
definitely they're far well being
sometimes especially the youth they
don't realize it and sometimes
unfortunately they have to realize it
the way tough situation like this but
and then you have the opposite side of
the car like he was talking about where
maybe it was there there
there are youth who go out and they
partake in these evil acts
she wasn't partaking she was just ended
up a victim but and then you have times
where the youth partake in the evil acts
and then maybe they end up dead
maybe they end up in jail right and the
projects along he said in them at my
Lubin how RT that indeed all actions
will be judged by the last one that
you've done so now imagine that you go
out and you make that wrong decision and
you die doing that decision you die
fornicating you die on drugs you die
drinking you die party when your Lord
has been so merciful to you and giving
you a message giving you a book giving
you guidance so that he can try to guide
you to his paradise guide you to its
kingdom so that you can live there
reside in peace and tranquility in love
with the king himself some kind of luck
it's amazing now let's say you have
Fatima in frontier ight now or you have
Muhammad for instance you know you have
a brother or sister and they're possibly
in the future maybe they end up in this
predicament where they have someone
who's enticing them who's tempting them
and saying come on look I'll pay for the
door I'll pay for the drinks I'll pay
for the gas just to get them to this
party right which is common in
university settings so many people just
go to college for the experience what
would you tell them what advice would
you give them I would tell them stay
away because yes it sounds like fun yes
it may be fun for the moment but at the
end of the day we are exchanging it for
eternal bliss over temporary bliss and
why would you give up something that's
eternal for something that's temporary
right this life is temporary it's going
to go away the only thing that we're
promised in this life is death right all
of us are going to meet it and when we
meet that then we have to meet our
Creator and when we meet our Creator
we're going to be judged for what we've
done and the injustice is only against
ourselves so yes if you hold on develop
ways to have fun right some people take
that Islam as Muslims we can't have fun
right well who said we can't have fun
our Creator didn't care
fun we can have fun we just have
parameters and we don't have the same
type of funnel or what people think is
fun right getting drunk is not fun
all right you wake up with a hangover
you wake up with a headache something
maybe like me one time I got drunk I
crashed my car I almost killed myself
right these are consequences right so
sometimes the Muslims just need to be
more creative and develop ways and be
leaders because they have to have that
identity of I'm a Muslim
and I'm proud to be a Muslim and I don't
need to follow you in order to be to
have fun but I can go ahead and be the
leader in that and it's Allah Allah if
you don't want to join me then that's
your loss because I believe that I'm the
most worthy friend that you should have
now she says that look you know she's
having a hard time because all the boys
keep telling her a teaser at school oh
you're so beautiful just take it off why
are you wearing this or other girls who
aren't wearing hijab say look you're
you're giving up your youth your
beautiful God made you beautiful should
show your beauty what would you say
you're a diamond all right do you go out
and leave your diamond on the table for
everybody to just look at it and be able
to take it from the table know that diet
that beauty is for you right and beauty
is not exposing yourself right if you
have to expose yourself to find beauty
then there is an internal problem you
may have a problem with yourself maybe
you don't think that you're beautiful
right because you find a lot of people
women who have to expose themselves
you'll find that it is - it's two-sided
right they expose themselves because
they think that they have to expose
their beauty but and then when the man
looks at her he goes she goes why are
you disrespecting me well why are you
showing yourself to me that way why are
you so surprised all right I just see
the video the other day that he's made a
video with the woman who went walk the
streets when it closed off and there you
got a mommy
can I talk to you come here you look gun
one man walked with her block right and
when she covered herself up
everybody resented her no one said
nothing's were to prove that when you
cover yourself and you cover your beauty
that you're going to get the respect
that you deserve but when you flock
yourself flock your body then they're
only going to seek after that and not
what's up here in your mind yeah they've
actually they've done a study we're
actually showing some images now where
the woman who actually wore hijab and
he's our statistical scientific studies
that they've done they actually have a
better self-esteem yes yeah so before we
go to break now that's interesting you
read my mind I was gonna ask you about
this video because I actually went viral
yes
so you had non-muslim woman do it they
had she was out there for 10 hours right
and exactly you had just man just
whistling you know taunting and this was
during the day but now you're walking at
night
some the last guy was going with her for
about five minutes wasn't he yes and all
he has to do now intoxicated during the
night just push her into alley and
that's it is over that's it so there was
some Muslims also who did the same
experiment and and then again
reiterating at the first taunting
whistling and whatever obscene remarks
but that had the lady the job yes right
not showing the revealing everything and
nobody said anything to him it's a word
so it was just simply respect everybody
seen her and kept on walking no
whistling no taunting no a baby and who
wants to be talked to that way
who wants he talks that way you want to
be respected for who you are you want to
be respected for your mind for you and
you want people to love you for who you
are and not for maybe something that God
has blessed you would have beauty we're
gonna be right back with more here on
the Deen show don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the video follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and now you hit it
that on now you spoke about the
importance of good companionship and is
this kind of where when you have those
good friends like when you're slipping
now your good friend helps too
pull you back yes right as opposed to
now you're slipping and you got bad
friends and they're not pulling you back
into the good zone they push you into
the bad zone yeah they further direct
they're dragging you further underneath
and I'll give you a good example of
another Muslim unfortunately a young man
may be about nineteen twenty hanging out
with the wrong crowd and his friend
steals a car at gunpoint and comes to
pick him up the muslim boy knows the
cars stolen he jumps in the car a little
while later the cops catch them they get
him down in the precinct right the
normal behavior separate the two of them
hey I have a friend the other noon tell
me what really happened and what Mika do
and the Muslim guy he's taking my friend
is never gonna tell on me so I'm gonna
hold off I don't have anything to say
they go in the other room
and there's and his non-muslim friend
the one who stole the car at gunpoint he
said he did everything he was the one
who took the car at gunpoint but he was
the one who did it but he was the one
who did it
he took the deal the young with some
boys in jail today
accompanied by a company wrong time
wrong place with the wrong person and
now he's paying for it and this is the
case this is what happens over and over
and over and over again you know and
that was why when I realized I had that
epiphany I was sitting on the porch in
my house with my friends smoking
marijuana and drinking beer right and
I'm Muslim I cool feel my head to
distinguish myself as a Muslim and it's
nighttime and I began to look into the
sky and I said I don't change how do I
know that this is not going to be the
last time that I'm gonna be here living
on earth that this moment maybe gotta
take my life and this is how my life is
gonna end high with these knuckleheads
all right I told me to get up and leave
get out and they were like you want to
get how you don't know how to act I said
no this is the first time life has ever
been cleared for me you need to get up
and go and when they left I made the
house my domestic I began going to the
Masjid on a daily basis and my friends
and my company became the Imams the
brothers in the message it all the way
up to today that I can say that some of
my best friends our scholars of the
religion Allah has replaced all of the
evil were people of knowledge people who
if they see me slipping they're going to
call me to what's right and help pick me
up they're not gonna say yeah come on
let's continue doing bad and if I fall
more than likely that bad friend he's
gonna leave me there and he's gonna keep
on going because he doesn't want no part
of it but that good friend he sees you
for he's gonna pick you up or he's gonna
sit there with you to find out how can
we resolve the situation right now you
also you've also traveled you know
overseas to study Arabic you're also at
the mission at university and you're
almost you've almost completed it
correct correct this Islamic studies
masha'allah hummed it aloud so now let's
say you have three Muslims and they're
you know we know Islam is the fastest
one way of life in the world today and
and you have new Muslim and now you have
some friends that brought you into
Salaam let's give a live example they're
Muslim they've been a Muslim for a while
you're a new Muslim now and now it's
been several years you don't you know
you come in you don't know much but now
you're seeing that these are Muslims but
now unfortunately some are indulging in
things that they shouldn't be indulging
in let's say these there's their cursing
their swearing you know they're not
adhering to many of the guidelines at
what point but you they kind of helped
you along you know maybe they even
helped you take sure how that you follow
me at what point do you say hold up I'm
not really taking it to the next level
right I'm not increasing my amount you
follow me my my character is not getting
at all so at that next level what do i
do you're in a tricky situation you know
you've grown attached to them
but you're seeing that look you know
they they're they're not helping me
improve to a level I should be you know
honestly the the easiest answer is you
may have to change the company no matter
how you may not like it but in order to
make that change sometimes you just have
to change your company Allah says in the
Quran man you hurry don't be a Coleman
had to tell you how you do may be
unforeseen you will never change the
condition of a people until they change
what's in themselves first so sometimes
you have to change you first and
sometimes when you realize right as a
Muslim we should always be looking at
ourselves on a monthly basis on a daily
basis on a yearly basis this is
something that the Companions always did
they always did self reflection
retrospective where am i compared to
where i was at yesterday and if there's
no development then i need to check my
stuff i need to figure out why there's
no development i need to go ahead and
start problem solving right and when you
find out what's the problem right away
you take it and you'll be moving out of
the equation because that's the only
that's gonna cause you to grow so what
should you be now monitoring your with
in the company that you're with your
iman should be going up shouldn't it a
man your faith should definitely be
going up it should be increasing
I'm not saying in large spurts but it
shouldn't study it should be going up
setting it should be decreasing now what
goes up and down but I'm talking about
every time you get around a certain
people now you feel like you know you've
already made me lose your Iman yeah
that's a bad sign that's right so around
the company that you're with they should
be reminding you about your Creator you
should be in good liquor circles but if
you're in a company now that again is
indulging in sin indulging in things
that are displeasing to the Creator
that's where you probably want to this
is yourself - I listen to you something
like you said the property is selling me
said that Eman increases and decreases
it's like a roller coaster right so you
go up you come down and go up and come
down mow down those Peaks that you're
coming down you realize I need to go
back up again right and you catch
yourself so that you can start going
back up again and that's what you have
to decide this on me it's a little
genius example you go to a certain
person's house and they're watching for
instance piece TV they're watching the
Dean show they're watching some good
lectures Iman starts to go up right you
start feeling really good no negative
side effects but now you go to the other
person's house and they got MTV they've
got the Music Awards they got the
daytime nighttime dramas a lot of
cursing going on and you just you know
you forget about Ojeda and you just
contrast Reitan duniya and now you know
you've seen 50 cent the bling blings out
there and you know you start forgetting
about your response salat passes you
follow me so this is nice and you have
two choices you can split or you can
first advice right because you realize
that there is a situation right yeah and
you can advise and tell the person
listen if you want me to come over if
you want me to hang out with you if you
want to be together I want to hang out
with you you my boy
you my man you might hold me whatever
you however you want to say you my
brother right and I want to be together
with you I want to hang out with you I
enjoy the time that we spend together
but I don't want to do this we can do
something else
right because this here I think is just
gonna get us both in trouble
and we need to be that you know I mean
that they're a for one another you help
me I help you and if they accept it then
you've done a good deal now you get the
reward for him leaving that as well
right but if he says nah you corny get
out of here if you want to leave then
just leave then you say okay ma'am you
know I really hurts me really bothers me
that that's the way you feel but you
have my number anytime you want to hang
out and you don't want to do this give
me a call and I'll come through and we
can hang out and miss a lot and then
maybe that according to be affected with
somewhere down the line if you guys
really have a good relationship like
that because that time sometimes people
are in the beginning they're stubborn
right but sometimes they reflect after a
while and say you know what Abdullah
he's a good dude and I do want to spend
time with him I do want to hang out with
him all right I can give up the MTV I
can give up you know me watching those
late-night novellas you were the women I
have addressed right so that we can get
together so you just have to make that
choice man I will first just give that
advice try to help change your brother
into a better situation even if he's not
a Muslim you can still do the same thing
I'll do the same thing with my family
you want me to come by no drinking you
want me to come by no smoking we I'll
come by a hangout what you do after I
leave that's your problem but when I
come through these are my expectations
and if you meet them I come through we
hang out we can spend time together
because I love you right so and most of
the time my family my friends they say
okay company we want you to come to me
you want you to hang out and after I
leave they'll go ahead and party in
there do whatever it is that they want
to do but what I'm there we'll go ahead
and have our fun the way we need to have
fun without those things about beautiful
because you're either getting down given
to you or you're giving a good Dawa so
monkey-see monkey-do sure yeah you want
to be doing good right yeah hamdullah
and the end reward now is okay you're a
good company and hopefully God willing
if you're at the University wherever
you're at you're gonna end up excelling
you can definitely excel and even
greater than that is that narration that
you said where the property some said
that indeed you'll be
those who love this doesn't exclude the
profit if you love the profits and you
follow him and you obey Him and you
practice what you're supposed to
practice from the teachings then you too
can be with him in the paradise on the
level that easily
and we shall are enjoying his company as
well as a person will be with whom he
loves but now if you love the profits
awesome you love the Creator you'll be
you'll see your Creator in general
you'll be with the profits awesome
agenda but now you'll pass those exams
hopefully with good company but now we
talked about and before we go failing
the ultimate test now we're being tested
in this life isn't it bad company you
have a great chance of failing the test
yeah I know you fell the test it's
something that you can never recover
from
you can't go back next semester and
retake the course all over again retake
the exam try to boost your GPA back up
once you failed failure means death and
punishment in the grave when you meet
your Lord and your book is given to you
in your left hand and set up your right
hand because in your right hand earnings
mean that you've done good and your left
hand it means that you've done evil and
you stand there for that judgment and
your Lord tells you you felt and now
because of your failure after me sending
you so many messages I basically gave
you the answers to the test and you
still didn't use answers that I gave you
for the test and you still fail the test
when I provided you with the answers and
the only outcome now is Hellfire because
of it
instead of paradise and this that's
right thank you very much for being with
us advising the audience and those who
aren't here with us today hopefully God
willing we can internalize this and take
benefit from it chuckle I'm so not
making it look easy and you got to hear
the beautiful advice good companionship
because this companionship that helps
you remind you about the purpose of life
why you're here when it's time for salat
you have that brother or sister
reminding you to pray instead of now
those people that you're with you start
forgetting about the ultimate goal in
life and you
missing the salaat you start staying up
late and you miss fudger
and you start drifting off and then you
end up at the end in places you
shouldn't be and you heard these
incredible stories now really sad and
devastating and I they take you away and
it just takes one traumatizing event
like this to ruin your life so if you're
in these situations where you have
companions that aren't helping you excel
to become a better person each and every
day maybe it's time to separate and
maybe come back when they're ready
because maybe they're not ready now so
you advise to good you called to good
and if they're not setting a call and
you got to move on to those who are
gonna help you to develop to be the best
human being that you can be and then
shell out and we can all be in Genda
together we'll see you next time here
Nadine so subscribe if you haven't
already follow us facebook twitter and
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you